[Music]
hi everyone i'm allison horst i'm an
assistant teaching professor at the
brenn school at uc santa barbara
and over the past year i've also been
our studios artist in residence
in this talk i'm really excited to share
with you some of the motivation
behind my r artwork and also some
lessons i've learned from the r
community along the way
to get started i want to ask you to
think about what did it feel like for
you the first time
you started learning r
maybe you were one of the lucky ones
where all you felt was happiness and
excitement
and you knew this was going to be an
awesome tool to learn
but for many people who are learning r
or code for the first time
that's not the reaction there can be
some confusion
at the idea of learning this new
language
there can be some frustration maybe you
are already happily working in another
language
and you're looking at r thinking like
what is a cacapo
i want my pandas back maybe you were
feeling frustrated
as you tried to get up this deep
learning curve
or maybe you weren't even expecting to
have to learn how to code
and you're looking at r just having a
meltdown because it's something that's
so completely new
and all of these feelings are pretty
common for learners and this
isn't unique to r a recent google search
for why is coding so dot dot dot
reveals that a lot of the top searches
related to why is coding so
are not totally positive why is coding
so hard
so boring complicated frustrating
difficult hard to learn
confusing and stressful and yes mixed in
here there's some good ones like
why is coding so important and why is
coding so
fun that might be an artifact of this
being part of my search results
but the overall takeaway is that for a
lot of learners
r and learning to code in general can
feel a little bit intimidating
and maybe not like a totally happy place
and not only can it feel a little bit
intimidating
but it's also a big energy and time
investment
there are so many things to learn to get
started in rn with coding in general
and there's always something new coming
out for those of us who are happily
working in r
maybe we are this green monster on the
right where
we see new tutorials and new resources
or packages coming out every day
we are so excited knowing that it can be
something useful for us to learn and use
but we can imagine that for learners who
are just trying to get up this
steep learning curve seeing all of those
new things coming out all the time
could be a little bit daunting so what
can we do when something
is hard to learn and we're asking a
learner to make an
investment one thing that we can do is
we can put in a little bit of extra work
to help something that originally
doesn't look
that appetizing feel a little bit more
appetizing
for example if we know that vegetables
contain a lot of really great nutrients
but it's hard to convince somebody to
eat them maybe we can dress it up to
look like a cute bug
to make it more likely that they will
invest in eating those vegetables
and people are already doing this in
code
for example julia evans zines that
explain a lot of really important basics
and css
and get and bash are really useful
teaching tools
because they provide information for
learners but they also make it
look very welcoming these look like a
thing that i would want to engage with
and i found myself wondering when i was
teaching courses in
r to graduate students most of whom
never coded before
do those resources exist in r are there
nice welcoming engaging illustrations
that i could include in my course
materials
that would be a welcoming entry way for
graduate students to learn new functions
and packages
because what i found was that i would be
up there in the front of a class
so excited to introduce an amazing new
function
and on the screen behind me would be
like a screenshot of the documentation
which contains a lot of really important
information that's going to be essential
moving forward
but maybe was not the most inspiring
first interaction that a student could
have with a new function
which made me think yes there is a place
to create
engaging artwork that dresses up r a
little bit
to make it look more inviting and
welcoming
and over the past year that has been my
entire goal
as rstudios artist in residence has been
to create useful and engaging
illustrations
that welcome users to explore teach and
learn about new packages and functions
and
are and they will still have to go on to
eat their vegetables
and learn those hard skills but the
first interaction
could be something that is fun and
positive and welcoming
so for example instead of their first
view of mutate being a screenshot of the
documentation
maybe instead their first interaction
with mutate could be
seeing these helpful x-men monsters
adding a new column to an existing data
frame
and over the past year i've not only
been creating many illustrations as a
welcoming
interaction with different functions and
packages in
r but i've also created illustrations
showing general data science principles
and concepts
and also a whole bunch of heck stickers
but what i want to talk about now is
what i've learned from the r community
over the past year
and these have been really important
lessons for me as an artist and as a
data science teacher
and the first thing that the r community
has helped me to embrace
is that cute and credible artwork
coexist
just like bailey the golden retriever is
sitting here looking
totally credible and professional while
he develops his our package
he also is looking very adorable
and that can happen with artwork too
and even though i knew this even though
i knew that making and including artwork
could be really useful for effective
communication making slides more
engaging
connecting to learners and clarifying
concepts
showing empathy lowering learning
barriers i just really love doing it
and also including artwork into course
materials can really help students
understand that yes creativity and
artwork have a place in science
even though i knew those things there
was always this little gremlin on my
shoulder saying
okay you can lean hard into the artwork
for r and data science education but
just know
that that might actually damage your
credibility
as a data scientist and there was a
turning point
when i realized that this was totally
unfounded
and that was when hadley wickham asked
me to create a series of illustrations
for an upcoming talk he was giving
called the joy of functional programming
and i was
so excited at this i knew this was going
to be like a big
talk a really awesome opportunity to
share artwork and i was expecting
that because this was a highly
professional
important advanced talk that that this
was going to be
maybe some sleek designs i was creating
to go along with the slides
and to my absolute delight hadley when i
asked him what style he was thinking
about
he responded that he was thinking about
these monsters
uh being included in this series and i
try to play it cool and be like oh yeah
of course the monsters would belong in
there but in my heart
i was just like oh my gosh the monsters
have made it
and and this is like cute artwork
being invited to be at the top level
talks in r and data science
not only were the monsters invited but
they were going to be baking cupcakes in
this series so really capturing for me
this idea that cute and credible are not
at odds with each other
that including cute illustrations can be
a really powerful teaching tool
at any level i think that one example
that captures this so perfectly
is the certified trainer badge from our
studio
which is one adorable but two is the
badge that's used
when the certified trainers uh get their
certification
which are some of the top educators in
the r community
and this has been a theme that has been
reinforced
with pretty much every interaction i've
had both with our studio
and in the art community is that there's
a refreshing
lack of ego about what educational
materials look like
and everyone is always just welcoming
and encouraging
more approachable educational resources
what that means is that well i started
with
this little gremlin on my shoulder
questioning my credibility and bringing
a lot of doubt into my mind
what i have now is the same gremlin
which is now encouraging me
and always asking can i actually make
this
more approachable or cuter somehow
the second big thing that i've learned
from the art community over the past
year
is that art truly can be a useful
teaching and learning tool that helps
learners engage with
and remember new functions an example of
the type of artwork i've been creating
is this illustration
for the string squish function the job
of string squish is to remove leading
trailing
and repeated interior white space from
strings
and here we see these four monsters who
are working together to squish this
string and in doing so
or ejecting excess white space this
combination of having
text and something verbally explained
and also an illustration
showing what that function is doing i
think is a powerful combination that can
help with retention
an example of this happening in the wild
is this illustration
that was trying to help people remember
to use
ungroup if they have used group by
previously we have in the forefront two
monsters who are at a
birthday party and you can see that one
of them has received this amazing gift
of group by
but more importantly for this
illustration we can see in the
background
this other little monster holding
ungroup as a gift
who is just so hoping they're going to
be included
and the reaction to this illustration
was exactly what i was hoping it would
be
which is an emotional reaction ensuring
that people will
not forget ungroup for example some of
the responses were
i'm so sad for that little bub being
left out
i'm always gonna remember this when
using ungroup
i'm never gonna look down on ungroup
again and my favorite one
is someone who said they were just able
to help someone else solve a problem
because they remembered this super cute
and somewhat sad
drawing and i think this really reflects
that artwork can be a way to engage
people's emotions that helps them
remember
important skills art can also be really
useful in helping to clarify
big or vague concepts for example
i recently worked with julia lowndes on
a series of illustrations
to try to portray the benefits
of working with tidy data and organizing
data and tidy data structure
and what this illustration is showing is
that if you have data sets that are all
in tidy structure
that you can use the same tools in
similar ways across
data sets but in contrast
if we have untidy data what that means
is we often times are hacking together
unique tools
to deal with unique data sets in their
own unique ways
which is challenging and tedious and
makes it hard to collaborate with people
so i think that this series was really
useful in taking some kind of big
picture ideas about the benefits of tidy
data
and capturing them in a way that is more
memorable
visually artwork can also make things
that are kind of intimidating for
learners feel a little bit more friendly
and provide a more welcoming entryway
for example
for loops usually aren't the thing that
learners are the most excited to learn
but they're especially intimidating when
it's just like sequences of numbers
and the code coming in and out that's a
little bit
daunting to look at so what if instead
there could be a vector that's actually
a parade of monsters
and in going through that for loop
depending on the shape of the monster
they are either assigned to get
sunglasses or a hat
and then what we can see is the outcome
is the result of each of those monsters
going through that for loop and either
getting their sunglasses or hat
and the third thing that i've learned is
that art can be
an incredibly powerful tool for creating
supportive communities
as a landscape painter originally i did
not understand
how important this could be but art can
be a way to directly show support for
learners
it can show empathy for example here we
see
this little bud who is just needing to
take a minute so it can be really useful
for showing
empathy when learners are maybe
struggling or feeling alone in the
struggles that they're facing
it can be a way to engage the community
by creating activities that include
artwork for
example with these coloring book
illustrations of our session aborted
and everyone's favorite object of type
closure
is not subsettable and it can also
just be a really cool way that different
groups and communities
can represent themselves and make other
people feel included
the most common way that we see this is
in the many hex stickers that exist
that different groups organizations and
even packages
are used to represent themselves
and i had no idea before joining the r
community
the power that a two inch by 1.73 inch
hexagonal design could have and this is
something
that i was so amazed by is the support
and demand for hex stickers that i think
really reflects how excited people are
to have something that they can put on
their computer or
whatever to represent themselves in the
groups that they're a part of
so in summary what i've learned over the
past year
and that has been reinforced by so many
people in the r community
is that creative contributions can make
coding and
r a more welcoming or even just a more
fun place
for learners and users at all levels and
knowing that
what can we do to create and support
more
art in our the first thing is
we can find ways to support creative
contributions
so what at whatever level makes sense
for you
how can you support artists and creative
contributors
just by watching this talk you are
supporting creative contributions
but you can also include artwork in your
teaching resources
you can like or share artwork that's
posted on twitter
whatever level makes sense for you i
guarantee that your support will be
meaningful for an artist and will make
them want to create
more the second is you could think about
ways to more formally collaborate with
creative contributors
for example can you contract an artist
to add something to your resources
can you write an artist into a grant
that you're working on
or can you create an artist-in-residence
program where i guarantee
you will have your work reflected in a
way that's really engaging for people
who might not have otherwise known about
or engaged with it
and finally i would ask you to think
about ways that you can be
a creative contributor so what do you do
that you might be able to share with the
community
we already have this amazing community
of people and so many of them
are creating and sharing incredible
artwork
and fabric and r-generated designs
3d renderings amazing graphic designs
made in gg plot and so many other things
and we should think about what other
types of artwork or creative
contributions would we want to
invite and the answer should be all of
them
baking music and sculpture dance
there is someone in the world who can do
the perfect
interpretive dance of pivot longer and
pivot wider
and i want to experience that memes
design poetry art and activities and so
much more
so that we can be creating artwork
and creative contributions that engage
and resonate with
every different our user who we would
want to feel included
and sometimes i think there's this
pressure if you're thinking about what
can i contribute
there can sometimes be pressure to like
feel like there has to be some learning
outcome
or somebody has to have a takeaway or a
new skill
and i encourage you to remember that
making someone feel a little bit happier
while they're
trying to learn something hard is an
absolutely great reason to create and
share your art
one experience that i had with this
recently was i was having kind of a
rough day i was mope scrolling through
twitter
and i happened to come across jacqueline
nolis's picture of the our pancakes that
she had created
and this didn't solve my coding problems
this didn't write my lecture for me
but what it did do is it made me exclaim
our pancakes
and then i just continued on my day a
little bit happier because our pancakes
had existed in the world
so to wrap up no art is not the solution
to text problems especially related to
inclusion and welcoming unless we're
talking about this
whale tail sculpture that is literally
saving a train that's gone off the end
of the tracks
art is not going to save tech which is
why i'm
so grateful for the many organizations
groups individuals and initiatives
just some of which are shown here that
have been doing this hard work to make
r more welcoming for more users since
before i even started using r
so while r is not the solution i hope
that it can be a supporting piece
that helps those efforts by making the
entire landscape of
r which is already so vibrant even a
little bit sunnier
i look forward to talking with many of
you about all the different ways we can
contribute
more creative things to the r community
thank you
[Music]
you